good morning Hank it's Tuesday February
10th and today I am finally going to
answer real questions that real
nerdfighters asked about my real new
book Paper Towns there shouldn't be any
real spoilers here but if you're
terrified of spoilers you can solve that
problem by reading the book
what does Paper Towns about it's about a
girl named Margo Roth Spiegelman her
next-door neighbor q the state of
Florida and Walt Whitman
how did song of myself' get to be so
central to the plot of Paper Towns two
reasons first song of myself' is a
beautiful poem that's deeply involved
with how we can imagine other people
more effectively and second Walt Whitman
is hot I mean that guy could sound his
barbaric yawp over the roots of my world
any time we'll Paper Towns ever be a
movie I don't know the movie rights were
acquired by mr. Mudd and mandate the
people who brought you such awesome
movies as Juno and I am currently
writing the screenplay so I guess it's
up to me whether or not it's good enough
to be made into a movie
our Quentin's parents based on people
you actually knew or on your own parents
know but I have had a lot of therapy how
did you pick the character names um it
would take too long to explain it all so
let's just talk about Margo Roth
Spiegelman Spiegelman is a german word
that means mirror maker like the dude
kneeled german villagers who made the
mirrors was the Spiegelman and Margo is
the Spiegelman of Paper Towns when
people look at her they don't see
anything that's essentially true about
Margo what they see is some funhouse
mirror reflection of themselves hence
the two different but equally inaccurate
covers I'm 20 years old am I too old to
enjoyed Paper Towns no in fact just
today I got an email from a woman who's
82 years old and she said she liked it
is the wake you miss imagines Margo
similar to the way that Pudge miss
imagines Alaska and your first novel
yeah definitely and I would also argue
that whenever we're imagining someone is
something more than a person whether we
read word colonising them or Alaska
izing them or Margo izing them we're
doing them and ourselves a profound
disservice I would like you to talk more
about the use of colors in the book and
what each color is meant to represent
well those of you who have read Paper
Towns know that there's quite a lot of
Moby Dick in it that sounds dirty but it
isn't there is also of course a great
white wall of cow and the bleached white
hallways at school and etc there are
also a lot of black Santa's and then
there's Margaret's middle name which
means red as Melville did in Moby Dick I
kind of wanted to subvert our
expectations that white is a symbol for
purity and excellence and I wanted Margo
to be outside that dichotomous realm
between what is good and what is
terrifyingly evil bara
I mean I'm just gonna say Hank that is
the first time in the history of YouTube
that a cow has had a fight with a black
Santa I'm a pioneer how many of the
details in your novel are purposeful and
how many are random well ideally nothing
in a novel is totally random does Ben's
beer sword represent some kind
inner conflict okay fair enough some
things are random is queue based on your
high school self not really actually I
don't think we have anything in common
except that we're both tall and vaguely
nerdy will Paper Towns ever be a
paperback yes the paperback will be out
at the end of this year but probably not
with either of these covers so if you
want these you got to get them now
where'd you get the idea for the black
Santa collection well if you've read the
book you probably know that it's about
how we miss imagine other people but
it's also about how we miss imagine our
stories that's why I wanted radars
parents to have the world's largest
collection of black Santa's hey I think
it's funny and B I think black Santa's
do ask us to imagine the world more
complexly did you ever find yourself
writing directly from experience very
rarely do i directly steal from my own
experience although if you click inside
my hands you will find two occasions
where i clearly did would you agree with
the opinion that you have written the
modern-day Great Gatsby
I mean look there's no question that
Paper Towns is concerned with many of
the same questions that Gatsby is Paper
Towns is a book that's deeply concerned
with whether or not there is such a
thing as the self-made man like is dr.
Jefferson Jefferson a doctor but ya know
did you have any alternate titles for
Paper Towns yeah for a long time I
wanted to call it more light than heat
which is taken from the line in Hamlet
when a hearts on fire it gives off more
light than heat and speaking of the
great gatsby for a while I wanted to
call it under the red the white and the
blue which is when it Fitzgerald's
alternate titles for Gatsby okay that's
all the questions we have time for
nerdfighters thank you for reading Paper
Towns thank you for responding to it
with such thoughtfulness in-depth and
reminding me of why I love my job
thanks for being awesome Hank I'll see
you tomorrow